miles de voces denunciando la corrupción
de la justicia en bolivia activistas
junto a familiares de víctimas de
feminicidio marcharon para exigir
cambios en las investigaciones y en las
sentencias para los autores de crímenes
de género el ratón es fotos de cuando yo
estaba toda quemada mi primera y cuarta
cirugía esto no vale cuatro años señores
jueces señor presidente señor ministro
de justicia por favor esta marcha no es
político está marchas por todas las que
se quedaron sin voz los investigadores
lo único que piden es para caminar
dinero mira deja que te que hemos tenido
que llegar a cuánto tiempo después se
encontraba mi sobrina enterrada en la
caja de richard choque el caso de
richard choque fue el detonante de la
indignación social condenado por
feminicidio fue liberado por supuestas
razones médicas en 2019 y detenido de
nuevo en enero después de que se
encontraran los cuerpos de dos mujeres
enterrados en el patio de su casa el
viernes la fiscalía de bolivia arrestó
al juez responsable de su liberación
repudiamos y condenamos la decisión el
juez que liberó al feminicida y violador
sentenciado a 30 años de prisión sin
derecho a indulto y que luego de ser
liberado siguió cometiendo crímenes
atroces contra mujeres exigimos una
sanción ejemplar con todo el peso de la
ley el ministro de la justicia iván lima
anunció el domingo una evaluación a más
de 1000 jueces ante lo que llamó un
iceberg de corrupción una medida para
intentar cambiar las cifras de un país
marcado por la violencia machista en
2021 según la fiscalía en bolivia se
registraron 108 feminicidios